(upbeat dramatic music)
- Nature. The most powerful
creative force on earth.
I'm Chef Melissa King.
Cooking has taken me to incredible places,
from TV competitions and celebrity galas,
to countries around the world.
I'm heading out to places
I've never been before,
to seek out new experiences
and to create new dishes
inspired by nature.
I'm teaming up with some of
the world's greatest explorers
to go further than I've ever gone before,
to push my craft,
creativity and my cooking.
This is, "Tasting Wild."
(wind whipping)
Hawaii.
The forces of nature that create
this lush and diverse ecosystem
are mind blowing.
You can feel the energy and
the raw power of the islands
the moment you land.
I wanna understand where
that feeling comes from,
take it all in,
and tell that story by
creating an original dish.
That's why I'm meeting
National Geographic Explorer,
Andres Ruzo.
Andres is a volcanologist,
who studied here on the Big Island,
and he'll be my guide to
this remarkable location.
(gravel crackling)
Hello, hello!
- Melissa, I am so glad
to finally meet you!
- How are you?
- Great.
Welcome to the biggest active volcano,
from base to top,
on planet Earth.
My name is Andres Ruzo.
And I'm a National Geographic Explorer,
working in geothermal science,
conservation and education.
I'm excited to see
Hawaii through her eyes,
see how she takes this in,
and puts her experience on a plate.
- I'm so excited to
see what grows out here
and just what we can
take inspiration from.
I've never been on a volcano before.
- One of the best ways, I think,
to experience geology is through flavors.
There's some things that
I think you might like.
- All right. I'm ready for it.
- Let's do it.
(gentle music)
- How does one become a volcanologist?
- My family grows coffee,
and has for the past four generations
on the side of the Casita
Volcano in Nicaragua,
and I would spend my summers
on the farm and like,
there's hot springs and
super heated waters.
- Wow. You grew up on a volcano.
- Pretty much, yeah.
- That's like the coolest thing ever.
(car vrooming)
I've been to different islands in Hawaii,
but this is my first
time on the Big Island.
- So what's really crazy about
the Big Island in particular,
is that you have all
these amazing ecozones.
If you go on Hilo side,
it's much more jungle feel,
it's much wetter,
it rains a lot more, right?
So, right now we're on the Kona side.
Even though this looks lush and beautiful,
it is much drier than we
would be on the eastern side.
- I love discovering the
regionality of cuisine
and just how different it
can be wherever you are.
The nuances of flavor-
- Totally.
- Really come from the land and the dirt
where that product was grown.
So yeah, I'm interested
to see what we find,
'cause that's really gonna
be the starting point
to the dish that I'm creating for you.
- [Andres] This is where the hike begins.
- [Melissa] Let's go!
(gentle rhythmic music)
- [Andres] You could
definitely feel the rain and-
- I love it.
It's magical.
- So, before they used
to rely on water wells
and now they're putting in
rain encatchment systems
to really take advantage of
every drop of this stuff.
- Sustainable and-
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, it's so important
for me as a chef.
A lot of my inspiration comes from
people that I meet along the way
and the flavors that I encounter.
There's just so much happening here.
All the different colors,
and plants that are growing
all next to each other.
I'm like, having sensory overload.
(Melissa laughs)
Oh, wow.
- [Andres] Right?
- Oh my god.
Smell that.
Where's the ginger?
- Bingo. Ginger.
- Oh, there we go.
It's so incredibly rich here.
- You have rocks being
eroded, being degraded,
ultimately creating soils.
And as a result,
I mean, you dig under this mulch
and you see this richness in the soil-
- Yeah.
- That's laying the foundation.
- I feel like a kid in
a candy store right now.
I see passion fruit right there.
They're ripe when they fall.
- [Andres] Oh yeah!
- [Melissa] Right there.
- [Andres] Good eye.
- Ah, it's such an intoxicating fruit-
[Andres] Mm hm.
- Like nasturtiums,
but it has a really
nice pepperiness to it.
- You can eat this one too?
- You can eat that too, yeah.
It's almost like a watercress.
(plants crunching)
- Yeah.
- There's a little pepperiness to it.
- [Andres] Yeah. This one's-
- And the blossoms you can
create like, a vinegar.
And so, there's a lot of fun
things you can do with this.
Are these limes?
I feel like every culture uses citrus.
It adds some acidity to
their dish and brightness.
All right,
I have so many ingredients
here to work with.
I think we're ready to go.
- And I wanna take you
to the core of the island
where all of this magic really starts, so,
let's get going.
This is a really weird question for you.
Have you ever cooked bugs?
- [Melissa] That's the one
thing that freaks me out.
- [Andres] Yeah.
(Melissa laughs)
- We're staying off of bugs today.
(Andres and Melissa laugh)
(car vrooming)
(upbeat rhythmic music)
The massive scale of this volcano
is truly something that I never imagined.
I wish everyone could get out
and explore spaces like this.
(air whooshing)
The changes of the
weather here are extreme.
We went from sunny and tropical terrain,
to cold, windy sideways rain,
and now we're here above the clouds.
- [Andres] The Big Island is
full of diverse microclimates
and we've gotten to experience them
in a rapid succession on this way up.
- [Melissa] Yeah, it's
incredible to experience it
all in one drive.
I've never driven anywhere like this.
It looks like we're on the moon.
- Mauna Kea here, from base to top,
it's taller than Everest.
Mauna Loa, this is-
- [Melissa] Incredible.
- Both of these are active volcanoes.
We're looking at
beautiful, creative forces,
coming in from deep in the earth,
forming some of the newest
land on planet Earth.
- Well, you can like,
feel the energy, the power of this place.
(Melissa laughs)
It's beautiful.
When was the last time this erupted?
- The last major eruption was 1984.
These are living mountains.
It's not something
that's just eroding away,
it's growing, it's active.
This is only a small piece of it.
The waters around Hawaii
between 14 to 18,000 feet deep.
What we are on, from here,
goes all the way down
to those extreme depths,
and it's so heavy,
it's actually weighing
down the sea floor itself.
It is one of the most creative
and inspiring places on earth.
- There's something here
(laughs) that's magnetic.
(wind whooshing)
- Get on those mountain bikes.
There's a place I really wanna
show you just over there.
It's called a lava tube.
One of my absolute
favorite geologic features
that you're gonna see on the Big Island,
volcanic Disney World sort of thing.
- [Melissa] Like, we have to see it.
- All right.
(wind whipping)
Since ancient times,
Hawaiians have come all the way up here
to pay their respects to the mountain.
- [Melissa] For me as a chef,
a lot of my inspiration
comes from pushing myself as far as I can,
to create dishes that I
never thought I could.
I've never mountain biked
at such a high elevation,
let alone on a volcano.
At this altitude,
biking across a lava field
is not as easy as it looks.
- So the entrance is right
down here, so we can stop.
- Stop here.
- Yeah, this is good.
So, I think the best path is over here.
So check this out.
As the lava's flowing down here,
you see these ropes.
- Oh, wow.
- It's so hot, it starts
melting its way into the earth.
You get a trench like this.
- [Melissa] Yeah, like sugar pulling.
- Exactly, sugar pulling,
like, viscous stuff.
So check this out.
It goes down,
deep enough to where the top part up here
starts to come in on itself,
totally closes over,
and then it's sealed.
- This is incredible.
- Now look down there.
There's an entire cave system down here
and this is one of the entrances to it.
- Oh my god. (laughs)
- I could go in-
- And just-
- Be careful.
- So I mean, it goes down pretty deep.
It's really just a spectacular formation.
- [Melissa] There's like,
plants down there, yeah.
- There's these drippings.
You see them like,
almost like icicles, but of rock.
And this is what ultimately
built the island.
- [Melissa] This is incredible.
Never seen anything like this before.
(gentle music)
Time doesn't exist up here.
It's so peaceful and quiet.
(gentle twinkly music)
- [Andres] Now, wait till
you see the night sky.
- [Melissa] So, what
are we gonna see here?
(doors clicking)
- [Andres] We'll start
to see the Milky Way
rise over the next hour.
(gentle ukulele music)
- [Melissa] This moonroof is so cool.
I just feel so tiny today.
(Melissa and Andres laughing)
(cymbals glistening)
Andres is taking me to a black sand beach.
We're gonna see where the lava
goes all the way down to the ocean.
I'm really inspired
and I wanna pour some of
that creativity into my dish.
(waves crashing)
I've never been to a
black sand beach before,
but what makes it that way?
- When you see different
color sands on beaches,
it all has to do with the minerals.
Lava can turn into rock,
erode away, and turn into sand grains.
- [Melissa] Beautiful.
- [Andres] I want you to
imagine a massive flow of lava,
coming down where we were yesterday.
(waves lapping)
- Wow. It's so much more fine here.
- And it's the same rock,
so coming up from deep in the earth,
coming up with the lavas,
it's the same minerals.
- Oh, man.
- You'll even see these lime green,
they're called olivine crystals.
- [Melissa] Those are beautiful.
- [Andres] And just over here,
you can see where the actual lava
flowed into the water itself.
- [Melissa] Trekking
across this hardened lava,
that originated deep beneath
the surface of the planet,
makes you feel connected to the earth.
And seeing the top of
Mauna Loa in the distance
where we were last night,
you can feel the massive
scale of the island,
and the full creative force of nature.
- And what's cool,
is it's all part of the lava's journey,
from deep in the earth to the surface,
and the force is so hard
that it's getting erosively reworked
to start its next chapter in the cycle.
And you can really see how the waves
are working all of the stones,
smoothing everything out.
(waves crashing)
- Thank you so much for sharing
this incredible moment with
me and all of your knowledge.
I'm really excited to
just take it all with me
and share my gifts with you,
so let's go and cook a little bit.
- [Andres] Oh, I can't wait.
- I'm gonna go to the car
and grab a few things,
but I'll meet you down by the beach.
(cymbals glistening)
I really hope that this dish captures
just the power and the
spirit of this island
from the volcano and the farm,
and all the beautiful things
that we've seen along the way.
- [Andres] Look at that
magic happening here.
This looks great!
- I decided to make a crudo today,
that's inspired by the
flavors that we've gathered
over the past couple days.
A crudo is a raw dish,
typically seafood with a seasoned broth.
It feels like the perfect way to reflect
the raw, creative force
that I feel on this island.
(gentle piano music)
- I can't wait to taste this.
(Melissa laughs)
It sounds amazing.
- As a chef, you can't
just put food on a plate.
It goes deeper down to the story of why.
Why am I using that ingredient?
We should start with
something fresh and bright,
and there's so many different
colors of the passion fruit
from the red to the yellow,
and smell that.
- Oh, that smells so good.
- And like, the little black seeds
kinda remind me of the lava rocks.
And passion fruit
is one of my favorite
fruits on this island.
Scoop that right into our crudo liquid.
Calamansi, it's almost like a kumquat.
And look at this fresh
ginger root that we got.
- Oh, yeah, that's-
- I mean, we have to put
some of that in there.
While we were exploring,
I took some time to cure
some local fish here.
It's called a nenue fish.
[Andres] Oh, wow.
- It's a white fish,
and I cured it in kombu.
This is just some seaweed
that we picked up,
right in the ocean,
cured it just for a few hours.
(gentle powerful music)
- I think it's so beautiful
to see all that like,
filtering through you to create this.
- [Melissa] It all comes together
when you travel to a new place,
and experience the colors and the flavors
of what's around you.
- So you've never made this before?
- I have never made this before.
It's really something that I think
is what's great about being a chef,
is that every dish can change, so.
- [Andres] So what is that?
- This is pickled shallots.
You have to add a little bit of texture
when it comes to crudo,
and so I pickled them, I sliced 'em,
there's some daikon-
- Ooh.
- That was just sliced thinly.
So I thought adding a
few of these sea beans
would kind of tie it all together
from the volcano to the ocean,
and those nasturtiums that
we picked up at the farm
also add a pepperiness to things.
Some lava salt, add a
little pop to the dish.
Final touch,
we're gonna add some heat here.
It's a Szechuan chili oil.
- [Andres] Ooh.
- To me, it was inspired
by the lava and volcano.
- [Andres] That's such a beautiful color.
It really is like that.
It's like a liquid sunset.
I mean, I love it.
(Melissa laughs)
- [Melissa] Liquid sunset.
- You've got me so excited to try this.
- And so, that's the dish.
(Melissa laughs)
- [Andres] Boom. I love it.
(gentle twinkly music)
- [Melissa] All right, let's eat.
- [Andres] This looks great!
- Please have a seat.
- Look at you.
- [Melissa] Here's a little hibiscus tea.
(waves crashing)
- Oh, thank you so much for this.
- [Melissa] Yeah, of course.
(gentle music)
- This is so good.
- Really, my take of
everything I saw on the island.
- The colors you brought out,
and the pairing of that chili oil
with the passion fruit as well?
- That's the Chinese side of me.
- It's a party.
- This place truly inspired
a lot of new flavors and techniques.
Thank you for that.
- I gotta take you out
on more field adventures.
(Melissa laughs)
I'm just sad 'cause I finished this.
- I'll get you more, don't worry.
Cheers.
(Melissa laughs)
- Cheers.
(playful ukulele music)
- [Melissa] This journey
on Hawaii's Big Island
has been such a gift.
It's impossible not to be
struck by the magical beauty,
massive scale and creative forces here.
I'm grateful for the adventure
and inspired by the experience.
(gentle ukulele music)
(birds tweeting)
(car purring)